12-time world champion demetrius johnson
makes his much anticipated debut at one
championship
the one for the highway
[Applause]
champion
well obviously i'm the number one
container i got a date with adrian
a world title showdown for the flyweight
gold
well adriano said demetrius was
dominating ufc i was dominating one
championship
[Applause]
everybody knows who is the best in this
division
if you know you know if you didn't you
know now
okay what i can take a knee to the jaw
get right back up
the rematch we've all been waiting for
we flew all the way from singapore
to calabasas california they are two of
the biggest names in one championship
who just announced a major
deal with amazon prime bringing five
fights here to north america it is the
vice president of one championship rich
the ace franklin my personal favorite
fighter of all time and world champion
angela lee the adam weight champion from
hawaii on this week's food truck diary
and i'm feeding them breakfast burritos
let's go
from my wallet to my check i don't want
it if it's skinny
[Music]
let's do it we got a very special
episode of food truck diaries we have
two of the biggest stars from one
championship we have the vp
of one championship
you guys know him as rich ace franklin
one of the most famous fighters on the
frickin planet my personal favorite
you're one of the reasons i got involved
in mma i used to wear your
brown and pink american fighter shorts
are my favorite shorts i had to wear
those because they stick out right even
if you were if you were watching a fight
at a sports bar and you did you couldn't
hear the sound or see anybody was like i
like that guy because he's wearing brown
and pink it stuck out that's right yeah
it got me and uh i mean you know this
this you also look like jim carrey who's
also my favorite comedy store legend i
can't i can't escape i haven't been able
to escape that since i was 16
unfortunately it's not a bad thing you
know
it's not not the best thing
i mean he's a legend dude
but then and then next you you got i
think the face of one championship all
the way from hawaii angela lee the
animate world champion the youngest
champion the history of mma where were
you 19 when he turned uh world champion
yeah yeah it was 19 years youngster
yeah so i appreciate you guys coming man
you're you're obviously in los angeles
to announce the big partnership with
amazon you guys are coming over to the
states we are coming over to the
american market you got what five shows
planned five big shows five shows for
for the remainder of 2022. uh the first
one being august 26th it's going to be
the rematch of adriana morias and uh
demetrius johnson so it'd be a great
fight one on prime video one mariah
versus johnson two that'll be the 26th
of august it starts at 9pm is the league
card and the main card is at 10pm
eastern time and that fight is where
that fight is going to be broadcast from
singapore but airing during prime time
oh gotcha so it will still be in
singapore where you guys you know do
your thing broadcast it here i guess you
could call this like our soft launch in
the us because all of 2022 we're going
to be broadcasting still from that side
of the planet we'll have shows in
singapore as well as various other
locations in asia but friendly to
american times all all the all the m all
the prime video shows will be during u.s
prime time so this one the main card
like i said starts at 10 pm league card
at nine and all the other shows for the
remainder of the year the schedule
they'll start at a similar time frame
but we don't have those those times set
yet
2023 is when we're looking to actually
be on ground in the us oh that'd be fun
yeah and uh angela so there's five big
fights are they i'm sure and and i was
talking about you're the pr guy josh i
told richards i think for
for one championship you know all the
you guys are brilliant you obviously
taken over the international markets or
crushing it so you're trying to do the
same thing here in the states i think
their road to success here in america
goes through you
no pressure no pressure no pressure
so if it fails no pressure yeah
but uh you know out of hawaii you look
at your fighting style you're a mama you
know so i think a lot of people relate
to it you know so for you with these
five fights is there anything i'm i'm
willing to bet i would assume chauchi
and rich find something for you to be on
one of those
major five fights yeah you know
definitely um
i'm super stoked about the deal and i'm
putting my my number in to get on one of
the shows um obviously
it's uh
you know it's huge um amazon amazon card
i'm super excited to see you know the
live events and
um showing on us prime time because i'm
sure in hawaii you're you know you're
the
the big the big name on the island you
know obviously hawaii has a history of
you know phenomenal fighter started with
bj penn he was kind of the pioneer of
that and you know bj might be your
freaking governor yeah you know he's
running for a governor
yeah he might i think he's gonna win be
honest but so you know obviously hawaii
loves their their fighters so i'm sure
this being more friendly to the time
zone especially for hawaii you know the
the fan base has to be excited about
that definitely you know in the car i
just searched like what 9 p.m eastern
time is to hawaii time that's 3 p.m um
that's it's perfect you know um people
don't have to stay up till three am it's
a great switch off and
um in hawaii everyone loves the fights
they support us like crazy the fighters
and i'm just so grateful to be fighting
out of there and now
you know it's accessible to everybody
yeah explain this rich because i think
for the american fan base one of the
things that makes one championship
special i mean obviously the production
value the yeah the talent the fighters
you know you guys have muay thai fights
you have high level submission grappling
fights then obviously high level mma
fights but also the thing that separates
you guys from a lot of other
organizations is the the weigh-in
process like the the the way the i'd say
the weight limit hydration hydration
thing right so you find the atom weight
which um
at the press conference uh yesterday as
someone one of the reporters asked about
atom weight and stuff like that like
using
confusion for fans like when victor has
adam wade you know so it's like they're
familiar with it but your guys is is
weighing kind of hydration
thing is a little can you explain yeah
yeah
i like this
for example when i fought at 185 i'm a
middleweight and but i'm walking around
at about 208 right and so i'm cutting
from 208 down to 185 really i'm walking
around at a light heavyweight wait in
essence so when we initially made the
switch all of our weight classes kind of
moved up so what you would call
light heavy weight here we would call
middleweight oh gosh all that being said
so there's a shift but all that being
said is that the the intent of the
hydration protocol what we do is that
when the athletes come in during fight
week they get tested for their hydration
and their weight so the process works
like this two days before the match you
walk in you
you pee you pee we test your urine for
the specific gravity see what your
hydration is if you're on hydration you
step on the scale you have to make
hydration and weight simultaneously then
if you do that a day before the fight
you repeat the same process you have to
make hydration and wait simultaneously
again and making hydration is what it's
making sure like make sure like if you
pee right now i can use a i can use a
like an instrument like a refractometer
it's like mountain dew yeah it's
hydrating yeah the less hydrated you are
the more yellow typically your knee is
and so you're testing the specific
gravity of the urine like getting all
scientific like but you're testing the
specific gravity of the urine which is
basically the amount of particles that
are in your yard and the more particles
you have in your euro the more
dehydrated you are
so it's safer for fighters it's also
easier for a fighter
i would assume you're getting a better
performance out of firestone they're not
killing themselves this is this is one
of the things i talk about i think that
one of the reasons why we have a 70
percent finish rate and really exciting
yeah in one championship is because the
athletes just want examples because the
athletes are fully hydrated so you're
you're not coming in and depleting and
performing like if you and i are
fighting each other and we both have to
cut it's like well we now have to manage
our weight cuts right so we're going to
come back and we're going to perform at
a percentage of our optimal level
because we've been dehydrated correct
right and so it's like well who can do
it better can i come back to
95 and you only make it to 90
so instead it's like well we're both at
100 performance level because we're both
hydrated and we're able to put 100 on
the line and i think that that's one of
the reasons why we have such exciting
fights yeah it also just makes sense
when you think about it because you want
the best fights possible if the guys
feel good and they're they're fighting
at an optimal level you can get a better
product well but your challenge is
explain like you know the commission
here in the states is what would be so
you when you guys come to the stage you
have to explain that to the commission
right yeah but it's not see here there
are there are other things that are part
of the global rule set that because like
we have athlete safety is a real
priority for us so for example our
organization requires athletes to do
fight week ct scans
just to make sure that you didn't like
because you're going to do your ct
during like your medical protocol yeah
like you did when you're fighting right
well you'll you'll do all that during
the medical protocols that we have for
you that are four or five weeks outside
of the fight but come fight week when
you show up we stick you back in the
hospital and ct your head again to make
sure that you haven't had any you know
damage from
training right wow and so
protocols like that and the hydration
with the the conversations i've had with
the athletic commissions here in the u.s
like there's no issue when you're going
above and beyond their standards
for approval because if a state wants to
approve you they'll say okay well here's
our minimum standards of approval well
you're gonna we're gonna do our weight
in hydration through third party anyway
we're gonna do the cts are technically
third party it's a hospital so any
protocols that we want to do above and
beyond their minimum standard they're
cool with they're in it so it should be
a pretty easy transition for you guys to
fight wherever especially some of the
more stricter commissions yeah in
california there's there's going to be
some commissions that are going to be
slow to adopt for sure but you know i've
i've personally have been back in the
u.s since june of last year i've been
working on our u.s expansion here and
one of those things is speaking to
athletic commissions i've spoken to
several of them that have already given
us approval in their states and several
others that are like well we we're
definitely interested and we want to see
kind of proof of concept here in in the
us i think too as far as you know one
championship expand in the into the
states i i think you're going to be a
big
part of that and then also if rich
franklin comes in and was like hey guys
this is what we want to do i'm sure it
gets their attention like and i'm sure
you know cha tree who's brilliant
there's a reason why you're
the face of this expansion you know what
i'm saying yeah i'll say this that it
probably makes a difference when i'm
calling an athletic commission's office
as opposed to just another executive in
the company
yeah dude
yeah hell yeah you call me i'm gonna
listen you know what i'm saying if if
freaking uh dale earnhardt juniors give
me tips how to drive my that makes sense
you know like with if rich franklin
comes in it's like hey this is what i
think we should be doing they're going
to lose way more than you know yeah you
are massive here dude
well listen
i'm going to try to stay humble on this
but yeah you go ahead and continue yeah
continue running with that
yeah
you're a great idea i love this i got
you dude so you were i assumed so uh
explain to me how how in the hell did
you get linked up with one championship
because you were such before you
answered because you were
you know you were such kind of the
poster boy for the ufc because when you
think about it the ufc and just mixed
martial arts in general had kind of this
you know storyline about you know rugged
dumb guys you know meat heads and then
you were a former math teacher what what
grade did you teach uh high school high
school freshman
to seniors so you know you're educated
dude you're hopefully good at math you
know you're you know your math teacher
decided to you know fight grown men in
your underwear in a steel cage so i
think we all make good life choices yeah
right so i think at that time it like
kind of portrayed the the mixed martial
arts especially the ufc in a different
light where people like oh these guys
aren't just these are real athletes like
they have other options no if you if you
actually i mean people forget even
10 12 years ago like i was just recently
watching a video where i was in germany
promoting at that point in time and the
kind of questions that we were getting
asked like so wait a minute you can
actually choke people and this was in
like 2009 right now it wasn't that long
ago yeah it's not and so people forget
that that was the state of mma but when
i was champion like we were you know
still being compared to human [ __ ]
fighting and explaining
the fact that these fights could go to
the ground and yes the thought of you
know in the western mentality the
thought of being able to hit somebody
when they're down and every film you've
ever seen is like somebody gets knocked
down like a cowboy movie it's like we'll
get up right yeah and so that we you
know we had to get that past that entire
stigma and i was exactly what we needed
here in the states at that time because
we were f we were fighting to get past
that in essence i agree and so
what coming full circle at the end of my
career like towards the end of my career
i went down to singapore to teach a
seminar um at evolve and just randomly
got hired to go down there and teach no
they reached they reached out to me and
actually i went down there with hume the
two of us yeah the two of us went down
there to uh to teach seminar i was still
competing at the time but for those who
don't know matt hume is uh dj uh
demetrius johnson's coach and he's also
involved with one championship matt was
my coach at that point
and matt's like you know he's the phil
jackson mma coaches yeah he's mastermind
that's why they're nice guys they call
him a wizard they call him the wizards
exactly he's the nicest guy ever until
he's so cool have you ever grappled with
them no oh god it's like crap on a wet
blanket really oh i don't know i'll tell
you i'll tell you a story about that
after this but but we i went down there
teach the seminar met some some of the
executives uh at one championship and
they were like hey if you would ever be
interested in a position when you're
done retired from fighting let us know
and did you want to do like you know
certain guys get done with fighting they
should like i'm good man like did you
see this like as a career choice um
not initially because i was still in
competition at the time and even when i
retired at first there was this
transition i can remember distinctly
remember after i took the job with one
sitting in the stadium uh for the first
probably year year and a half of events
and the whole time i was sitting there i
hated it because i'm uncomfortable i had
the same feelings that i had as if i was
sitting in the locker room triggering
right exactly and it really took me
some some time to actually escape that
to be able to sit and and and watch the
matches kind of change your
the way your brain works
to this day it's tough for me to go to
fights yeah yeah
it's triggered but with that being said
i've done so many different things for
for one championship i ran um i did a
travel show called one warrior series
it's called rich franklin's one more
series where i traveled around recruited
talent with a production crew and you
know we told the stories like whether it
was like something cultural or whatever
we got into and and you know i initially
helped set up like the merchandise
department for one and just did
several different things like and so
like
i don't know if i'm a jack of all trades
but i'm kind of just slotted in where
where they're lacking real talent maybe
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll try to say it
that way yeah so then uh
i assume you watch the fights you watch
everything like all organizations are
just one championship no i i stick to
mostly one championship and then i'll
watch some of the bigger matches here
and there but it's it's just difficult
but you know keeping up with ufc
bellator pfl and you know eagle fc is on
the rise now and there's just that's
right there's so there's so many
organizations out there that
when you sit and talk fight fight fight
fight fight all week and then your
friend's like hey man you wanna you
wanna watch the fights this weekend i'm
like no it worked all week nothing worse
yeah right
so it's uh or when you break down a
fight and then i'll be at starbucks so
i'm like hey man what did you think of
uh you know angela versus uh stamp i'm
like can you listen to the podcast dude
yeah like did we have to do this
what's up think fam let's take a little
break from chatting with angela lee the
champ and also one of my faves rich
franklin and we'll get right back to it
because i got something to tell you guys
about lately i've been listening to a
lot of music a lot of podcasting and i
do it when i'm running when i'm on my
bike but look at my ears
they're not designed for earbuds that's
why people make fun of me when i post
videos when i'm riding my bike because
i'm i got wires in and why is that
because my ears are like tortellini's
until my friends at raycon wireless came
along they're the best earbuds i've ever
used i'm telling you the only ones that
fit my ears because they come with
different gel tips i can fit it to my
exact earpiece so now you're not going
to make fun of me anymore with the cords
that's it man raycon's everyday earbuds
look feel and sound better than ever
with optimized gel tips i'm telling you
dude for the perfect in-air fit that's
why i ride with raycons they don't budge
trust me it's the only wireless earbud i
can use that's why i love raycon that's
why i've asked them to be part of this
show part of all my shows raycon gives
you eight hours of play time a 32-hour
battery life raycons are priced just
right you get the quality uh audio at
half the price of other premium audio
brands it's no wonder raycon's everyday
earbuds have over 50 000 five-star
reviews they're fantastic noise
isolation awareness mode all right the
earbud i just tap i tap for maximum
volume when i'm on the bike you're
cruising dodging a rattlesnake i just
tap it all good let's tap it okay go to
dot com shop s-e-h-a-b today to get
fifteen percent off your recon order
that's buy raycon r-a-y-c-o-n dot com
shop s-e-h-a-b to score fifteen percent
off by raycon.com shop enjoy a lot of
y'all been waiting for this vacation
with your mans or your woman or your
kids and you're going international and
you don't speak a lick of the language
don't be that weird random dude who's
lost search around this foreign town why
don't you pick up some skills once you
pick up another language it's easy take
it from your boy my girl's super mexican
my kids talk trash me in spanish i have
no clue what they're talking about well
i'm gonna let you in on a little secret
there's babel that's right babel they
make it fun and easy it's bite-sized
language lessons there's still time to
learn a new language even at my age dude
people say oh you're too old to learn
the piano wrong you want to learn a new
language i got you guys covered babble
you only need 10 minutes you got 10
minutes to learn a new language we all
have 10 minutes all right um other
language learning apps use ai for their
lesson plans not my friends at babel
lessons were created by over 150
language experts all right and it's
scientifically proven to be effective
we're taking the guesswork out we're
talking about science with babel you can
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian german
your boys on spanish so i know what my
kids are saying about me all right we
got you man there's so many ways to
learn with babel it's so much fun start
your new language learning journey today
with babel you're never too old fam i'm
telling you i have ct and i learned
spanish right now when you purchase a
three month babel subscription you get
an additional three months free that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com use the promo code shop
s-h-a-u-b that's babel b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com promo code shop
now let's get back to the program
because we're eating breakfast burritos
so uh yeah it's interesting man it's
it's cool what you guys are doing it's
cool you're at the forefront of it and
then for for you android i i would
assume
you know because hawaii's such a small
community and you guys take so much
pride in your fighters and you know
there's a lot of you know talent out of
hawaii so the gym you train at is there
a lot of young talent and then i would
assume
you know it is especially in the states
you know kids grow up you know they're
not saying i want to play in the cfl
like everyone's goals the nfl so i
assume at your gym you know there's it's
in america it's like oh i want to be in
the ufc and they're like hold on
have you looked at one championship
because you've never fought for any
other organization like all you know is
one championship i feel like you've had
it good you know what i'm saying because
you're fighting one championship
yeah definitely in hawaii
they they know one um because there's a
lot of one champion fighters um from
hawaii and and they're just fight fans
in general right so yeah um but because
christian and i um you know we teach
classes at united um
and uh the next generation coming up you
know they're exposed to seeing us
fighting and one and um you know so
there's other options and i think it's
important that they have you know other
options not just like ufc like you know
when i first started doing mma
everyone's like yeah you know you you do
ufc like that's cool i was like no man
it's mma it's different so now there's
uh that distinction going on and
everyone's getting more educated and um
yeah like i said they're they're
watching what championship shows they're
tuning in and uh it's great speaking of
young fighters young talent
what about your
sister talk about that yeah
how old is she she just turned 18
actually um just graduated in may
graduated high school uh she wants to
follow your footsteps she already is
three times already you know as a
professional mma fighter and that was
before she turned 18. yeah
yeah so we're i'm sitting here like
angela's angela's youngest title uh
record may actually get broken by her
own sister no she's good too man she's
talented we actually did this um
piece on the two of them where they're
training like they're doing the same
drills and it's like a side-by-side
video and it's
pretty it's really i'm getting chills
i'm no joke i get chills it's cool like
watching the two of them because they
are it's like shadows of each other just
watching the train yeah do you want your
sister following your footsteps i want
her to do you know whatever
whatever is her passion and she's so
talented like she
she's smarter than the rest of us like
she she's got the brains
she honestly her
her style is is different it's like a
combination of she's a christian like
uh
so when my dad started teaching us um
you know he taught all of us growing up
when you're little your dad who's your
coach now yeah he's been yeah my only
coach and um yeah you know his style has
changed and he's uh
evolved and developed you know and shown
us new techniques but i think the fact
that she also has christian and i as
like
coaches and mentors to help her yeah i
mean she gets the best of everything so
yeah she's way better have you ever seen
soldier with kurt russell old school
yeah yeah right remember he was like
engineered as a child like that's that's
they're they're dead ken that's what
he's done with his entire family they're
all killers they got younger brothers
and sisters they're killed too all of
them i mean they'll be the lifeline of
one championship you just keep signing
all the family yeah i think their
objective is to relate
erase the other league
but your dad's background is what um so
he you know he grew up doing martial
arts um but he kind of self-taught he
went to different gyms he actually also
trained matthew
yeah um that makes sense i was just like
one years old and matt remembers me the
first time you saw me he's like i
remember i seen you you were just a baby
and i was like what
i it's before my time right but yeah he
went around training and and his whole
thing was about you know self-defense
and so for self-defense you need to know
all areas stand up ground and um
yeah so he
he's had a lifetime martial arts and
one thing he wanted to definitely pass
on to us is to be able to protect
ourselves so um
grateful for that yeah yeah he wanted to
protect you from like a mugger or
something with a purse he didn't think
you're gonna be a world champion you
know jesus christ this one got out of
hand yeah i think he did he just because
like don't let her fool you her mom's
not champion oh yeah guys
it's the whole family man
yeah oh yeah my parents are they are
they're really humble they don't like to
talk about themselves but they are yeah
you don't either yeah you guys are real
humble yeah i dig it yeah i did that but
uh before i feed you guys and you don't
have a fight coming up rich you're
retired so you can eat too you see
you're in shape that right like that
yeah you shake what do we what do we got
on the menu today uh today it's like uh
if so it's uh a bun in a blanket bun end
blanket so i think they're known for
burgers but they they're doing a
breakfast early we're shooting this
early they're doing a breakfast kind of
thing for us it's just breakfast well
just wait until you watch me try to
order then oh me too too many nightmare
um but before i feed you guys um
my my question for you and chauchary is
like you guys are
and uh
to be honest i was naive to this as well
like the the amount of exposure that you
guys have internationally and like how
big one championship is compared to
forget ufc forget all these other
organizations yeah i mean you guys you
look at the nelson ratings it's
not so yeah that's like i'll be honest
like i went to the press conference
yesterday and they have the nelson
readings i it shows like how big is it
or not it's like second i forget what
was first but like you guys are massive
yeah like i knew you were big and
everyone's like yeah one championship's
big outside the u.s i'm like okay cool
you know i knew it was but you don't
realize how big it is so my question
would be
you i mean you guys got the market
corner outside the uh the united states
yeah like why who two chairs here
yeah on the nielsen report yesterday
there was a stat that i cited that we
were
ranked in the top five a broadcast
viewership tv viewership for sports
properties in 2021 and you know we're
broadcasting 150 countries but the
reality is it's like you know
when you look at sports properties you
look at some of the biggest sports
properties in the world nfl for example
right nfl nba right nfl is one of the
largest sports properties in the world
and that's primarily an american sport
people outside of america really don't
they've tried expanding yeah it's just
not and the nfl will continue they're
doing games in europe now and it will
help with international exposure and i
think some of it's catching on but the
point is that they got that number one
spot
just with the united states alone and
that's the power of the sports market
here in the u.s and that's why you know
we've captured that side of the planet
and it's time for us to come here
yeah i'm excited man i'm excited i think
you guys are doing it right you got a
great team you got great talent and you
guys also you know like the way you
found stamp fair tags oh
monster she just came to like a try out
like an open tryout so that was part of
the show that i was shooting
you guys were to hold tryouts i i so i
did a travel show and on the travel show
sometimes we would hold tryouts and i
held a tryout at uh at um in bangkok
there at uh martial arts school and i'm
literally i'm sitting there i'm sitting
there watching these two guys trying out
on the mats and they're doing pad work
and doing their thing and i just hear
this this cannon going off like i've
told you where is this at in bangkok so
there's just like a million muay thai
fighters yeah and also
i hear this kick i'm like i'm like what
the heck can i look over and i and i see
this little girl kicking the pads i'm
like oh man you know this this girl's
talented i didn't even have to watch it
in the rest of the tryouts i'm not even
looking at the guys trying out i'm like
staring over here at this other girl
like
yeah yeah so muay thai unicorn yeah and
so immediately like the moment we pulled
her in the organization knew and and
she's got a great backstory as well like
a lot of families in thailand their
children they use their children to
prize fight and that helps contribute to
the household income so you'll see
footage of of stamp fighting at the age
of six jesus yeah yeah she's so sweet
but she's such a nice little thing
and then one championship was like uh
cool stamp uh fight angela yeah and
answer like cool story stamp so here's
what's gonna happen
i'm gonna submit you yeah she landed a
good body shot though oh yeah and that
was after what a two-year layoff
year layoff like you were inactive for a
little bit um it was two years two years
yeah because you had a baby right yep
baby boy or girl girl well
is she signed already to one
championship or what's your deal here
you know i said yeah
i'll tell you this much so i was asking
her yesterday she told me that her
daughter's already walking but the
reality is her daughter's already
shooting she's duck walking and shooting
dogs and throwing side kicks and ken's
already got her going she can't walk
when she throws a mean spinning back
kick yeah i'm not gonna lie she watches
us in the gym every day you know oh
she's downloading all the data she does
she punches me in the face oh i'm
telling you she got it rascal so you so
you had the baby then you came back and
whose idea was it for no like because
usually you know especially with your
status in one championship you usually
can request like you know it goes rich
you have a long time off you don't jump
right back into the pool of you know
monsters kind of want to warm up but you
just decided on a huge card like stamp
fair tax and she you were in trouble a
little bit there she landed that body
shot you know stamps is a beast but then
once it went to the ground it was came
over yeah man so that was the fight that
was the fight it got called i was like i
never turned down a fight and i was like
yeah let's do it but i just knew i
needed the time you know it was a long
camp like
my longest camp ever felt like was going
on for a long time but that's what i
needed to get to the point where
um you know get back to where i was and
and and
yeah that fight was great um i had to
feel good taking that long time off
becoming a mama and then your you know
stamps no joke
that's a dangerous fight on top of it
it's not it's not like that she just
fought stan but we we ran a grand prix
of all the best atom weights all the
best female atom weights and then it was
like the creme de la creme yeah and
stamp won that right exactly rolled
through that monster so it was like the
toughest of the tough comeback for her
and stamp's outfit at the press
conference definitely
you know won the mvp for outfits yeah
she came in that traditional thai outfit
yeah yeah i didn't recognize her when we
were in the hotel same yeah i was like
who's this celebrity
until they said
all right let me feed you guys let's do
this
all right
let's take a little break from chatting
with the legend rich franklin and the
champ soon to be champ champ angelo lee
at one championship because listen i'm
talking about security you can't hire
andrew lee myself and rich franklin
protect your house all the time just we
can't we don't have the time we're too
busy all right there's better ways to go
about it and i'm here to tell you about
my friends i'm talking about home
security with simply safe simply safe
home security can trust it man simply
safe is advanced technology that puts
the safety of me and my family first
here's why i love it and i have it all
around my crib with 24 7 professional
monitoring simply safe agents call you
the moment a threat is detected and they
dispatch police or first responders in
case of an emergency even if you're not
home you're on vacation cool they're
still working for you they're taking
care of it so you don't you're not so
stressed out while you're on vacation
you're on tour whatever it is simply
safes monitoring agents truly care about
your well-being and are highly trained
to help keep you calm and safe during
stressful situations standing on line
with you the whole time to the help gets
there simply saves customer first policy
make sure you're taking care of listen
affordable plans start less than a
dollar a day no long-term contracts no
hidden fees because feeling safe at home
shouldn't break the bank customize the
perfect system for your crib in just a
few minutes you got a few minutes cool
go to simplysafe.com
shop s-e-h-a-b go today and claim a free
indoor security camera plus 20 off with
interactive monitoring just go to
simplysafe.com
shop
now let's get back to the program
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks for doing this man of course
thanks for having us yeah short notice
early are we allowed to order off menu
oh okay well i'm going to go healthy on
us you know i am yeah you can't you
can't be this age and look this way
eating
egg sandwiches don't make us feel bad
listen i'm gonna let you all go first
what are you thinking um i'm gonna do
the breakfast burrito
yeah with the sausage sauces
thank you thank you
rich got you ordered and then you know
i'll vibe off that i don't know i don't
know i don't be the fattest no i want to
see i want to see what you're going to
do no no no no i always see what your
order dude but here's this is the reason
why this is a bad idea because whatever
you order isn't going to change what i
order yeah but but what i order is going
to 110 percent right well like well i
would eat healthy okay i'll tell you
what she's currently fighting okay so
she can get you know all right whatever
you and i you have an egg white option
okay sweet i'll tell you what i want i
want 12 egg whites
yeah i said that right and and
there you go that sounds good man two of
those
he's sticking to his nutrition too yeah
two of those
yeah and he wants it
i'll do the same thing i'll meet like
rich franklin today thanks sir
appreciate man thank you appreciate it
man
[Music]
well got the food it looks delicious
you've already uh got started in yours i
don't blame you now i wouldn't be very
up front rich i was trying to
copy your diet and then uh
i saw andrew's burrito listen i will
trade you this chia pudding for half of
your burrito
before rich recognize what's going on we
could send somebody out to go get
another a burrito order for you i was
trying to kill with your diamonds i'm
just not made for i don't think a half a
burrito is going to be enough for you i
think you're going to need another baby
you know what i actually don't eat that
much you know what here's the thing i'm
you know i've been carnivore i cheated
here and then every if i'm like with my
kids at the movie i'll cheat on my
current over diet but since carnivore
like i'm messing up the brand man i'm
becoming you know thin boy it's not good
it's not good it's gonna ruin the
business
what do you weigh now uh
like today i'm currently probably like 2
47.
246 but i was
man i was 272. i mean you look good yeah
thanks man yeah yeah yeah so do you know
how many how many how many calories you
eat in a day do you couldn't tell semi
juice sometimes i all uh intermittent
fast during the morning and then you
know especially like a monday or tuesday
i have so many shows i won't
realize i didn't eat anything to about
three four o'clock can't be healthy but
no your boy's losing weight yeah no are
you trying to lose weight i don't want
to be big no no no no no only too big
what's your ideal weight then oh man
done me dude don't get me started i mean
i would love to be like 220. 220. even
though i look like like down to 20. i
know like three would be sweet dude no
we'd be sweet too training partners
just be real skinny
yeah i eat north of 4 000 calories every
day oh damn
but you were notoriously known for
having all your your workouts like your
training camps were nuts yeah that was
the
the word around town around the the
water cooler of the boys yeah your
workouts were nuts you still i'm sure
there's still
a degree of that i'm sure your workouts
aren't like you know no when i go to the
gym man i tear it up like when i'm in
the gym it's just the difference is the
volume now you don't when you're in
fight camps you're training 25 hours a
week and now
i'm training
seven or eight
but when i'm in the gym man i'm on it
like all right yeah intensity
and for you angela you your dad uh
creates all your camps like as far as he
he does conditioning everything
yeah yeah everything in house
damn
is it is it
i don't know a conflict of interest
having your dad as your head coach
i know he's like
always looking out for my best interest
so that's one thing i never have to
question but
um you know
it is tough you know we're family you
know disagreements here and there
sometimes you know right you i mean you
work together and around each other all
the time yeah which is good and bad
yes yes definitely imagine what those
family fights are like right like
her husband's a world champion black
belt
so
i wonder what like arguments in that
house is like
dicey no we're very good
i'll just be like i'll see you tomorrow
training yeah
[Laughter]
see you tomorrow it's sparring day
little sister's talking [ __ ] see you
tomorrow at the gym um
uh rich where did the the the idea come
up with
to to expand not just mma but doing the
muay thai and then also the high level
submission grappling that was uh that's
chaucher's idea to be honest with you i
wasn't a fan
like when he hit we were we were on a
call one time like one of our meetings
and he how long ago is this
uh it's been
years yeah now i mean because i'm
thinking like time is just like time
warp since covet and everything right i
mean it's like so it seems like it was
just last year but i know it's probably
been three or four years now and he was
like i want to do submission grappling
more time and we were in this meeting i
was like you know i thought who who
wants to go to an mma man like an mma
event to watch
muay thai
um so i'm sitting there i'm watching the
first the first event with muay thai in
it and i was like
man that was good because i had a little
more time right and i was like that was
good but i don't want to like it still
like i tried i tried to still not like
it you know yeah and uh and it was just
so good man and you know with the muay
thai that we do with the four ounce
gloves
and um and then we just we kept adding
things and so the whole concept it was
he was the brainchild on that and it's
yeah
now that now that it's unfolded i'm like
okay
that was a great idea remember i've
always championed this idea but yeah i
would like to pretend like i was that
guy that was like remember when we came
up with the idea
exactly but um
i do like i i think it's a hardcore and
i watch everything you know i love it i
love the uh the submission gravel
especially at that high level it's great
to see muay thai is great and the mma is
great and then you guys even
mixed it with dj yeah where it was what
a round of muay thai and then a round of
straight up mma yep
again it was dj in a raw tang rate
savage super savage but
what do you say that match too
i remember thinking if i was dj i would
have gone out in that match and i would
utilize like a clinch
just to eat time off the clock right
because they were three minute rounds so
i'll come in and i will clinch all he
has to do is get through that first
round exactly don't get knocked out
exactly shell up like a turtle he didn't
until about
maybe a minute and a half a little over
a minute and a half around and like he
saw he was exchanging it i know alright
i was like come on dude what are you
doing
you're representing all of mma but you
know he
he got it done it was it was nice yeah i
loved it it's different i think a lot of
people dug it
i do think coming over the states if if
you know that's where i think educating
the american fans on it because you know
kickboxing even though there's glory at
a super high level here you know a lot
of other kickboxing muay thai
organizations have tried to
do well in america for whatever reason
it just doesn't it hasn't caught on and
i don't know why because think about mma
everyone will see a knockout all they
care about is stand up they hate when it
goes to the ground not everybody but
they love so it's like well you know
this is guaranteed not to go to the
ground it's just at the highest level to
the highest level strikers in the world
so i don't know if the message or
if it's just bad marketing i don't know
what's going on there but if you guys
could figure that out well i think you
know that's up i think that um
i think that what ends up happening with
our event
is that we have the right balance of
things you come in
you're going to see a card 10 12 fights
on the card
probably primarily mma fights but then
you're going to have one or two muay
thai fights
one or two kickboxing fights
a submission grappling match and so you
know in a 12 fight card you know you're
gonna have
six seven mma matches and then these
things get sprinkled in so you don't
you're not sitting there watching
kickboxing back to back oh yeah yeah so
then when you see a high level you know
we had jonathan hagerty here yesterday
so when you see a high level uh high
level stand up fighter like that and his
elbows on oh my god such a savage i
think that in those kind of doses it can
be appealing to the american audience i
believe that this this event because
we're not an mma event this is something
the american audience has never seen
outside of the whole production quality
of it is like this is a different kind
of event and i think that that's what's
going to appeal to the audience here i
think especially right now and you know
uh
especially in america it's like it's
you know the entertainment value right
and like i think with uh one
championship like the walkouts are very
i'd say prideish if you remember the
pride fcc like it's very pridish with
that
and then you know the the production
value is super high but then it's also
it's it's kind of like like he says the
press comes kind of like a uh you know a
rock show mixed with fighting like it's
this high level like high energy kind of
product yeah which i think americans can
relate to and that kind of separates you
from other organizations were you in the
studio that day uh i think it was joe
rogan show when eddie bravo was talking
about his experience down when he came
to singapore yeah yeah yeah yeah i
thought you were there on that episode
and he when he was talking about it like
being being an executive for the company
and seeing what we do with those like
the led screen and the computer
computerized like all these all these
like custom walkouts for the athletes
you know it's
like it's highlights and computer
graphics and all this and then that's
mixed with like a laser light show and
then pyro and that's an event you know
smoking and
when you work in that environment and
you get used to seeing it
you forget and then suddenly you see
somebody like eddie come in and they're
like they're sitting there watching it's
like wow this is amazing and it's a
unique like these are these are custom
done for every athlete that walks out
that's nuts
they'll have elements of like cultural
like you saw stamp yesterday yeah at the
press conference
and so they'll have cultural elements
like that intertwined into their
walkouts and so it's just it adds a
whole different level of hype
and it translates on tv
but when you're when you're live and
personally in person yeah that's why
it's yeah yeah i think too like the you
know obviously you guys are huge
internationally like especially in the
asian market they're more educated on i
feel like mixed like they don't you know
boo when it goes to the ground or even
it's a boring fight they don't boo you
know they're and they're not as
uh animated as americans right like we
yell you'll hear like rip his head off
right so um you know asia they don't
they're very respectful and they they
kind of it goes to the ground they can
appreciate like you know passing guard
again the side control and stuff like
that in america there's less of uh an
attention span almost you know they just
want to see the entertainment value so i
think it's you know
educating the american fans on that high
level grappling once they see it at the
highest level in the kickboxing muay
thai
once they understand it it's on i mean
you remember like even when when i first
won my title like east coast fans man
like the moment that the fights hit the
ground
man it was you three seconds and you're
getting booed and you've seen this
education level because it doesn't
happen anymore i'm boston here you're
gay like a takedown dude no but like now
it's it doesn't happen because you know
and i think on that side of the planet
the the fans over there were unfamiliar
for example i traveled to myanmar have
you you've seen left way matches before
yeah yeah so left way is a lot like muay
thai kickboxing for anybody that's not
familiar with it but they allow
headbutts and then
traditional deathway they fight without
gloves and so when you see that you're
like man this is this is brutal when you
travel to a country like that they look
at mma as being brutal
and so
you start explaining things and i'll
just say that you know we traveled to
countries where they didn't even know
what mma was and we were able to educate
and close the gap and seize those
markets like
really fast really fast
and you with with chauchi i guess what
makes him kind of the out we can end on
this with with chauchi obviously
you know coming over getting that deal
with amazon is massive you know you have
five fights so we broadcasted here on
amazon you know to the american fan base
as far as him as the vision i just you
know i see his moves and everyone tells
me how brilliant he is
and obviously he you know had the the
iq to hire you and sign you and he's
doing the right things i don't know if
that takes a whole lot like
yeah wait wait wait why are you such an
outlier like i don't hear you know
promoters it is what it is you know
they're
they're running the circus so you know
it's a tough gig but i don't hear a lot
of bad things being said about chauchary
which is unique when it comes to fight
promoters you know yeah um
when you look at the company like our
company is built on a lot of the values
that you get from martial arts right
honor and respect and integrity and
courage and these are the reasons why
you like people put their kids in
martial arts they're self-defense but
you also want them to you know learn
things like respect yeah and so you know
the entire company was was built on that
and we we have this kind of athlete
first mentality when it when it comes
those kind of things so
i think that's a lot of the reason why
you you know you don't hear these kinds
of things yeah
because
yep well i'm glad you guys uh
i like to think you guys came all the
way to l.a to do this food truck but i
think you're here to you know celebrate
this amazon no actually i came here i
came here for the food truck diaries uh
but then i figured i might as well hit
the press conference while i was here
that's what i'm thinking you know that's
what i'm thinking well uh
dude i've been a fan for a hot second
man i love what you're doing with one
championship and angela you're i told
you this i think you're the the the cash
cow for one championship to break into
this american market so hopefully you
get a big fighting out soon so americans
can tune in and i wish you guys the best
best man keep crushing it both you guys
rich franklin anjali
everybody 12-time world champion
demetrius johnson makes his much
anticipated taboo at one championship
the one
[Applause]
champion well obviously on the network
dinner i got a date with andrew marias
a world title showdown for the flyweight
gold
well adriano said demetrius was
dominating ufc i was dominating one
championship
[Applause]
everybody knows who is the best in this
division
if you know you know if you did it you
know now
okay what i can take a knee to the jaw
get right back up
the rematch we've all been waiting for
you